so as a person who appreciates the game
uh
who do you think is the greatest poker
player of all time
that's a that's a tough question
um Can an AI help to answer that
question can you can actually analyze
the quality of play right so the AHS
engines can
can give estimates of the quality of
play right
um
I wonder if there's a is there an ELO
rating type of system for poker
I suppose you could but there's just not
enough
you would have to play a lot of games
right a very large number of games like
more than you would in chess it
determines the game makes it easier to
estimate yellow
I think I think it is much harder to
estimate something like ELO rating in
poker I think it's doable the problem is
that the game is very high variants so
you could play you could be profitable
in poker for a year and you could
actually be a bad player just because
the variance is so high I mean you've
got top professional poker players that
would lose for a year
just because they're on a really bad
um bad streak so yeah so for ELO you
have to have a nice clean way of saying
if player a played player B
and a beats B that says something that's
a signal in poker it's a very noisy
signal it's a very noisy signal now
there is a signal there and so you could
do this this calculation it would just
be much harder
um but the same way that AIS have now
taken over chess and you know all the
top professional chess players train
with with AIS the same is true for poker
the game has become a very computational
um people trained with AIS to try to
find out where they're making mistakes
um try to learn from the AIS to improve
their strategy so
now yeah so the game has been
revolutionized in the past five years by
by the development of AI in this sport
the skill with which you avoided the
question of the greatest of all time was
impressive so my feeling is that it's a
difficult it's a difficult question
because just like in chess where you
can't really compare Magnus Carlson
today to Gary Kasparov
um because the game has evolved so much
um the poker players today are so far
beyond the the skills of like people
that were playing even 10 or 20 years
ago
um so you look at the kinds of like
All-Stars that were on ESPN at like the
height of the poker boom
pretty much all those players are
actually not that good at the game today
at least at least the the strategy
aspect I mean there might be still be
good at like reading the player at the
other side of the table and trying to
figure out like are they bluffing or not
but in terms of the actual like
computational strategy of the game
um a lot of them have really struggled
to keep up with that development now
so for that reason I'll give an answer
and I'm gonna say Daniel negranio who
you actually had on the podcast recently
I saw was a great episode and I love
this so much and Phil's gonna hate this
so much and I'm gonna give him I'm gonna
give him credit because he is one of the
few like old school really strong
players that have kept up with the
development of AI so he is trying to
he's constantly studying the the game
theory optimal way of playing exactly
yeah and I think a lot of a lot of the
old school poker players are just kind
of given up on that aspect and and I got
to give them the Grandview credit for
for keeping up with all the developments
that are happening in the sport yeah
it's fascinating to watch it's
fascinating to watch where it's headed
um yeah so there you go some love for
Daniel